porque es el magistrado más antiguo de
la corte suprema de eeuu pero después de
28 años de servicio el juez progresista
stephen breyer y 83 años anunció a
través de una carta dirigida a la casa
blanca su jubilación que entra en vigor
este jueves en la misiva señaló que fue
un gran honor ocupar el cargo en el
máximo tribunal y dio paso a la que será
su sucesor a usted no me no y el senado
estadounidense lo ratificó a la
honorable y kentucky brawn para
sucederme en el cargo y entiendo que
ella está preparada para tomar el
juramento prescrito para empezar su
servicio como el miembro número 116 de
la corte player sirvió al alto tribunal
de eeuu desde 1994 cuando fue nominado
por el entonces presidente bill clinton
destacado por mostrarse contrario a la
deriva conservadora que ha tomado la
corte recientemente botón contra de la
polémica decisión de revocar la
sentencia roe versus way que protegía el
derecho constitucional al aborto en eeuu
también descendió al fallo del derecho a
portar armas en público protegido ahora
por la constitución su retiro no cambia
la tendencia política del máximo órgano
y marca un hito en el país
y las que han tenido que pasar 232 años
y 115 nombramientos previos que una
mujer negra sea seleccionada para servir
en el tribunal supremo de eeuu pero lo
hemos conseguido y netflix su puesto lo
ocupará la primera mujer afroamericana
en la corte suprema que tan he brown
jackson nominada por el mandatario joe
biden jackson prestará el juramento de
su cargo vitalicio al mediodía en una
pequeña reunión presidida por el
presidente del tribunal supremo john
roberts